what was the genesis of this project how
did it come to be I Norman had written
an autobiography and and was it would
had you read the book or what was their
simultaneous what happened well the
initial connection was that his
organization people for the American Way
had seen our film Jesus camp and honored
it and is limited and it blew my mind
and got several other things they've
done so was I guess somewhat of a fan of
our work and then we ran into him on
another project and it turned out that
his memoir was coming out and I think
that just put him in the right mood
that's maybe someone else could give a
crack at his life he's given his own
crack so it was time I think he felt
like it was time for someone to do it
what was your initial take on how you
were going to approach this film and
what was the inspiration for the
approach you took well we read the
galleys of his book that was the first
thing so we have this incredible you
know architecture for what would make
sense and for us you know I was really
reading the galleys and in getting on
the same page of what our takeaways were
and for us they both were that this
childhood like all of our childhoods
affects everything we do forever it
doesn't matter who you are these are the
things that inspire your art that
inspire your emotions and we needed to
figure out how to do that in a way that
was visual because it's a movie so it
just was a you know a collaboration
between us and production designers etc
to figure out what that was going to
look like and we really didn't know what
exactly what it was going to look like
until we were almost done editing so a
collaboration right until the end
there's been a lot of talk about how
things haven't really changed as much as
we think they have and I find myself
remembering watching the premiere of all
in the family with that disclaimer
thinking that as a kid I was going to
see something that I shouldn't so I
stuck with
from your perspective Norman what do you
see as have things changed our things
better are things worse well what what
keeps you going and what is your well
that's you want what keeps me going is a
separate question okay okay that's a
lovely in the moment you know rachel is
hurt me say this off and I don't know
whether I don't really even remember
what I say it in the film but the two
little words that are so important that
we don't understand the importance of I
think of as over and next something is
over it's over and we're on to next but
if there was a hammock between over next
that would be what I think is meant by
living in the moment so I'm aware
sitting here I I taught about this as I
saw Rachel 10 minutes ago for the first
time in a couple of weeks it took me 90
for years some weeks and days because
the birthday was recent to get just at
the moment where she walked in the door
and I saw her and it took me every split
second of my life to this instant to see
what I can see out here and sit here and
talk to this group who dared to come out
on a Sunday and and I love you for
coming out as a matter of fact I have a
check for each of you well so Rachel if
you're looking at this from your
perspective in seeing this subject that
I assume you had some reverence for what
did you do to maintain some kind of
subjectivity to your approach to your
work well he lives on the west coast and
we live on the east coast so that was
one way to do it we interviewed him
several times and then we went into our
little edit world and didn't talk to him
for a while so we had you know we were
able to just look at our material and
figure out what was going
make it and what wasn't going to make it
so we separated and we couldn't worry
about him and what he was going to think
of it you know what were the what were
the things that surprised you the most
and or that you felt were things in the
documentary that that you didn't expect
people to know well obviously the
grandfather's story was something that
happened within the first half an hour
or something of us doing our first
interview so as soon as that happened I
was like oh he's full of surprises which
is a good thing and for me it made me
totally engaged in the story even more
than I already was of course we were
excited about doing this film but I was
like this is complicated people are
complicated and you know just things
don't go away things are with you you
are who you are forever and just that
idea is so rich and exciting and
interesting to me so that was a surprise
but also it opened a door of of how we
were going to explore this how are we
going to explore not just someone that
was 94 but that had had this long life
the successful life and what does that
mean it in the end it means that you're
just like everybody else and that is
somewhat comforting i guess to me well
let's see my bumper sticker has read for
some years just another version of you
and they picked that up and i think
that's the truth whoo that's who we are
versions of one uh did you that choice
to talk about the grandfather story in
the fact that after saying it for many
years as that we see on but many
television shows to suddenly say you
know I made that up weird how did when
did you arrive at that point and what
brought you to the point of admitting
that probably the instant I said it like
but might the path I was on was to
explore the reality and talk about the
reality and the truth of my existence as
I saw it so you know I've had insights
in in recent days that just stunned me
and I think you know there's a
horizontal journey we make in life in
which we're learning about a lot of
different things all the time something
else and then there's that vertical
journey into oneself and and I think
there were the hidden truths you know
things that we never thought of that we
suddenly understand and it never ends
and it's a it's exciting we know about
your father we got a hint of the mother
anyway so where did your drive or your
self-confidence or whatever you want to
call it where did that come from because
we all assume or we all kind of feel
like that's something we inherit and
clearly it isn't and clearly there are
kids who need to know you may not have
gotten that where can you get it from so
where do you feel you got it from I
think I got it from my father i fought
not to be like him and there were three
words that i remember early on count on
me I wanted my friends certainly my
family count on me because I couldn't
count on him and I so I I think it comes
out of that kind of conviction you know
I I want to be somebody you can count on
hmm do you have any thoughts on that I
think you can't count on them I mean
that was actually one of my observations
that maybe it's obvious but and then
maybe it's it's old-fashioned but he is
professional he shows up he is prepared
he works hard it's just that it's just
the recipe for success it's not you know
obviously smart and clever other things
but like just works hard and does it
shows up gets it done and it's a good it
was a good reminder to me that it's not
like some some in special sauce it's
about just doing it just showing up and
doing it but look at what you do it with
who you do it with I mean I've had you
know life is a collaboration another
thing that is you know you either are
interested with as you wake up every
morning in every minute of your life I
might my mind skips to a question
somebody asked me after all in the
family had been on the air a little
while and people were asking about the
cast and somebody said what is Jean
Stapleton like and I said she's always
where she is and I don't know whether
that Minotaur sometime later it dawned
on me my god isn't that isn't that
amazing I heard myself she's always
where she is a nest was the truth about
her and I knew with several families on
the air on one family in NC no I wasn't
always where I was so even while working
with her I wanted to be more like like
Jean Stapleton some of the actors became
so identified with the roles that they
had Carroll O'Connor and Jean Stapleton
and and you know mary hartman mary
oliver almost even be Arthur they had
all had long careers and very
distinguished careers and yet this this
is these are the roles and they're
remembered for did that how did how did
that become a day-to-day thing for you
to deal with that that but there's very
pretty totally they're totally
responsible for it you know I thought
often I've said off and you know but I
knew Bea Arthur so that was that was
different but I broke all in the family
and I had I had an archie bunker I don't
know when I had in mind
had something in mind but I didn't have
Carroll O'Connor fine I couldn't have I
did to have his face I wanted to meet
him because I saw him in a Blake Edwards
film what did you do in the war daddy I
loved his face and I wanted but I
couldn't imagine that he would do what
he did when he sat down and read it
before he read our page I knew oh my god
so the Marvel of a performer coming in
and wrapping himself in the words you
know oh my god it was a glory and those
are iconic serve a sort of women have
come to me actresses wishing to do Mary
Hartman again and I said we could do
something like Mary Hartman but you know
she was indelible Louise Lasser Justin
doable I feel that way about Archie and
Maude I would like to thank you both for
being here thank you for making this
film of thank you thank you so much